I recently bought a 3D printer
not even gonna clap
I had one many years ago and it was
god-awful and I hated it but now I find
out that the new ones are actually not
even that expensive and they're pretty
decent
what the [__] is this what's cool about
3D printers is that anything you can
think of you can just go online and
someone has already modeled it for you
send it to the printer and boom there
you have it
that's so sick
for babies no we're 3D printing really
shines is when you make your own things
to solve your own completely pointless
problems but it makes you feel good okay
it makes my life at least 0.00 better
look like my monitor okay my stupid lamp
wouldn't fit my monitor I 3D printed my
own version I'm living big up here okay
there's just something so damn
satisfying of getting the perfect fit
for your things like I could never find
a just a box I just needed a box with a
thing in the middle so I could fit my
contact lenses left and right boom is
that too much to ask apparently it
doesn't exist no problem anymore I 3D
printed it amazing perfect thing I
wanted to hang up my surfboard on the
wall
perfect Bay
yes there's nothing like it I could
organize my shelves have all the stuff
perfect day I started printing all these
kind of random stuff around the house
and I think I got to a point where I
felt pretty done I don't need to print
anything more for now at least but then
I saw online people were printing stuff
for the public where you get the perfect
fit to public places and I thought that
was really cool so obviously as a
YouTuber I see something then I want to
do it but then I realized I live in
Japan and leaving plastic out in public
the country that has literally no trash
on the street probably not a good idea
but I don't need to do it anyway
I decided I wasn't actually going to
leave anything maybe Max a day or two
and then I'll come and pick it back up
again I just wanted to make it for fun
so I decided to challenge myself and
make three different prints for the
public and the result
might surprise you
[Music]
for the first one I had no idea what to
make so I went outside to look around
see if I can find inspiration and then
it hit me street mirrors that's right
these are everywhere in Tokyo because
there's so many sharp corners and turns
it's just so you won't hit another car I
bet you have it in your country
somewhere too but if there's one thing I
know about Japan is that they love tiny
things tiny things so cute same thing
but tiny it's so cute so I started
modeling my own version it was
surprisingly easy and it turned out
pretty good but time to test the perfect
fade will it perfect thing all right our
first
oh it's also double mirror never mind I
only found a single one
[Music]
I found my first spot this is just a
test really but so where I find this one
gets the shittiest one
all right the first one fell off a
couple hours later I think the heat
messed with the plastic so I made
another version with a rubber band to
make sure it would stick
[Music]
thank you
that's actually kind of cute I have no
idea if anyone saw it I have no idea if
anyone liked it I have no idea if anyone
hated it but I did it
laughs
kitten was laughing and smiling at it
all right that's the first one I placed
them around in three different spots
around Tokyo left it for a day and I was
actually kind of proud of it and of
course whenever you're proud of anything
you gotta show your mama so I did and I
was trying to I think I was a little
self-conscious she loved it but I I said
oh uh the reason I'm doing it is for the
cats they also need a mirror right but
my mom pointed out well what about the
snails feelings what about the tiny
little bugs aren't you gonna make one of
those so I did
it's so tiny it's ridiculous anyway tiny
mirror success
moving on to the second product I really
wanted something that I could leave in
public or at least for people to find
but I know I couldn't do that but then I
thought there's a really cool place
there's a Temple called gotokudin Temple
it's where the story of the beckoning
cat I'm sure you've seen it it's a
symbol of Japan it's where that comes
from that's templing specifically so if
you go there there's a ton of these cans
they're supposed to bring good fortune
and money I like Good Fortune I like
money even more I was gonna make my own
can't so I downloaded blender for the
first time I spent a couple hours just
messing around and oh my God he is so
cute he's got a thick more I was
surprised I was really uh very pleased
with this little kitty I was gonna make
a necklace for him I just couldn't be
bothered I had a thick version cat I
thought I should make a strong version
cat
[Music]
foreign
no I should not have that man probably I
had a thick one and a strong one I
should make a long one and no stop I
really had to stop myself here okay
obviously I can't just leave these at a
temple
I don't know what I was thinking I think
I got a little carried away creating
stuff the way this Temple works is that
if you go there you can buy one of those
cat that they have and you you can place
them there it's a great way to support
the temple and feel like you left a mark
there you're allowed to ride on them but
then I noticed hats people make hats for
their canes so I can make hat for my cat
finally my cat can be the anime
protagonist so I made a 3D version of
the actual cat in the temple I made my
hat I made a cowboy hat because who
doesn't love those subtract this model
from the Hat boom Perfect Fit cowboy hat
my Nicky nickel
wrong way
yeah it's very pleased thanks for saying
I was very pleased I like mine so much I
made one for Mercy as well she got a
little party hat and I have more ideas
as well I'll be right next to each other
yes I'm so pleased that looks so good
and I was so pleased for the result very
happy look how cute we are I love it hat
cat hat success who knows I don't know
uh but yeah good decision is a great
Temple I recommend you visit it if
you're visiting Tokyo but remember be
respectful it's a temple people come to
pray okay don't be annoying don't be
loud thank you
[Music]
for the third and final project I really
wanted to push myself with everything
that I kind of picked up from whatever
and I thought I should do something
completely different I looked around
Tokyo for more inspiration and I I
realized on almost every street leading
to a station they have sort of a
shopping street they usually have
different mascots they have sometimes
they play music from speakers it's
usually a really nice Street leading to
the station and I noticed they also have
different street lights every single one
of these streets in Japan or Tokyo for
some reason have a slightly different
version of a Street Lamp which I think
is pretty cool
the first time I see it
so I wanted to celebrate that and make
my own again miniature version of an
actual Street Lamp I don't know how to
do that but it can't be that hard
wrong 3D printing is really good for
sort of this size I would say you can
get amazing details but once you go
really tiny with with my printer at
least I was hoping I could print this in
like two or three parts but I think it
ended up in like 12 or something it took
a lot of trial and error but I finally
got it to actually print out all the
parts that I wanted but then I had to
build the damn lamp thing and I thought
for some reason just to make it harder
for myself
that I was gonna add a solar to it
because I found these tiny solars
they're so cute it's tiny it's tiny to
look small maybe it's just me that like
small things maybe I'm projecting onto
Japan
well it's gonna have to run on a battery
of some sort it wouldn't make sense if
the light is on all the time like it
should turn itself off when it's dark
and I realized that would require
soldering and I didn't know I [__]
hate soldering it sucks I feel like I
need at least four more arms to do
soldering what the [__] is this but
thanks to Indian YouTube never thought
I'd say that
I found someone that had made the
circuit that I needed I basically just
copy it put it all together and
work fine thoughts
what do you thinking
let's go into the line it's still quite
dark in here actually
I hit all the wiring in the side of the
thing itself which I think really sold
it to make it seem like it's one thing
then it was time to test it out will it
work or most importantly will it fate I
need perfect fate it's getting dark so
we're trying to make it there in time I
hope it's gonna work I feel like there's
so many things can still go wrong with
all the lights are turning on already
I'm nervous
if I'm one of them is white I didn't
I have white lights I didn't know all
right but we're just gonna accept
you can change that uh I no
I'm putting this up
so good
and then there's the light sensor so
yeah it's gonna be brighter later and
there we have it I was so pleased with
how this turned out I felt like I
learned so much I am aware like all of
this is completely pointless I left most
of them out just for a couple hours I
decided to leave this one for for a full
day I posted online to if people wanted
to check it out I thought because I was
so pleased with it so I left it out
there and I spied on a couple people
walking by just to see if there was a
reaction zero
everyone walked past it and didn't look
at it look up everyone is on their Farms
look out it's right there
no I don't think a single person has
noticed and we saw so many people what
can you do I learned
bye
I left it there for 24 hours and I
posted on Instagram if people wanted to
check it out they can do so and the
result was very I guess we shouldn't
have been surprising but for me it was
very surprising people were leaving
notes what so I guess people took it as
a chance to write messages to me which
was all very cute and I really
appreciate it but uh that made me also
realize I cannot keep this lamp up here
after posting about it it was gathering
way too much attention than I thought of
all right we're going back to get the
land I haven't watched online people
posted and that's got a lot of notes on
it and I don't wanna
it's a fun surprise but I don't want I
don't want to make a Nations or people
complaining I wasn't planning to keep it
in for long anyway so we're taking it
down
checking out the notes very cute I feel
like there might be people we'll see in
a second I met with a group of people
that I was waiting hoping I was going to
be there and they were also lovely thank
you so much there's people there's a ton
of people just hanging out by a lamb
[Music]
thank you
foreign
take down all the notes and we made sure
everything was 100 back to normal they
were so sweet I didn't expect anyone to
be there maybe maybe one like stumbling
by one guy had been there for three
hours it was funny they were like so
happy that they all got to link up as
well so that was really cool some
positive fun tiny things so ah huge
success I'm very happy you guys are so
sweet it's ridiculous I'm going through
the notes they're so nice said they
voted for me on King of the web does
anyone remember that that was ages ago
apparently there was an in-jo they were
offering people tomato juice because
there was people hanging around so if
anyone showed up they would give two
managers I don't get it but it's kind of
funny
they offered me some decline I hate
tomato juice thank you guys you know all
of this was just for fun I wanted this
to just be something positive if someone
met happened to see it maybe they were
confused or maybe it made them smile I
don't know but it was really fun to make
so that's it bye
interrupting this video to let you know
about today's sponsor which of course is
you got it nordvpn greatest VPN not just
because it has Nord in it
I swear I've been using nordvpn daily
for years now keeping me getting access
to the entire internet as it should be
but your VPN goes way and above to
protect your own life with amazing
features as threat protection and now
also dark web monitor dark web scary
place previously if you sign up to a
website and that website gets hacked
your compromised and you might not even
find out about it nordvpn got your back
they're constantly scanning this for you
let's get real here you sign up to a lot
of weird websites it's okay
norvpn does all this job for you and
scans the dark web and let you know
you know know that you ignored VPN just
got your back they're always announcing
new cool features they also have mention
it now which lets you to access your
computer files from anywhere turning
your own computer into VPN kind of but
you get a huge discount on a two-year
deal if you sign up with my link in the
description nordvpn.com PewDiePie click
the goddamn link because you also and on
top of that get one additional month for
free you're welcome
we got a deal at only if you use the
link all right
thank you novpn for sponsoring this
video